we're going through inflation masks
remember we talked about the fact that
we're investing now right we looked at
how to earn money that's just you know
you've got a job that salaries wages etc
we were told the allowances that came
with that other ways of getting money
now I think you know what happens when
you've got the money and what can you do
with it
okay investing it putting in a bank
account that's pretty standard now over
the weekend I posted the video on simple
interest part of the reason why I'm
happy to be involved with us because we
simple interest last year in fact we
looked at compound as well but come back
to the trickier so that's why I'm gonna
slow down pal
I just don't you remember how simple
interest work so you can do this all on
the piece of paper that you've got there
simple interest let's start with the
formula for simple interest which I
think most of you remember it starts
like this I equals now one of the three
letters the car
PRN very good now would you all pop that
at the top of your page I equals P RN
and I want you to help remember with me
the periods is the best way to say okay
usually it's years but it's not always
easy could be months maybe weeks if
they're a big bank whatever it is okay
I have PRN and you can see that the
interest really depends in terms of the
money it depends on that principle right
now this is the important bit the
principle here
principals are named for what's the
beginning what's the the starting value
the initial value of the bank account
how much money you put in okay so I'm
actually going to write their initial
value because that's a more helpful name
than principal it's like what do you
start with okay
now coming back out here the whole idea
of interest since the years you're
giving money over to someone else they
want to pay you for the right now having
your money and being able to do it as
they've leave a business venture or
invested or do any kinds of things like
that
so therefore simple interest works by
paying money to you or whoever is any
money based on this the initial amount
right so that's what I'm gonna put here
initial amount okay so you put in a
thousand dollars now pay you interest
based on a thousand dollars you put in a
million dollars if you're lucky and
they'll pay you interest based on a
million dollars it's all about this
initial amount okay compound it just
feels a little bit different it is the
same idea it's still interest but every
year right every year they recalculate
so rather than okay first year I get
patents in on interest
second year I get paid the same amount
and on and on and on you'll get paid
more and more and that's why it's called
compound interest right it gets bigger
and bigger every year is calculated as
if it were a new amount right
they look again it can't and they say
okay well no the end of the years past
you've got more in them so we'll pay you
more interest based on fact on more
money better so let's have a look at the
same amount of money say that interest
amount of time and let's see how simple
interest in compound interest the
numbers work today okay
so simple interest here's a table you're
gonna see this in your textbook so
that's why I thought I'm warmin for you
here you don't have to copy out the
whole thing the idea is that you want to
see how as time passes the bank account
is growing and you want to work out all
of that you want to do the number
crunching you'll be happy helpful to
have you calculate there if you haven't
already
okay sir you can see the three columns
are balanced plus interest what's the
total balance after you've combined them
and then now you have a total balance
well what interest we'll get paid to
your account
at the end of each year um you can see
I've grayed out the first one why is
that great because it hasn't been in
there for any amount of time it's the
start of the first year so they haven't
paid you any interest yet so that's why
I haven't put anything there
okay therefore the total balance what
you're beginning with is just that
principle about 2,400 they're paying you
6% 6% per annum so what are you going to
put over here on the right hand side
what calculation will give you that
figure yep okay yeah now I'm just going
to pause here you've got requests please
point this out for that on your
calculator you have to set fun okay I'm
actually going to encourage you now that
we're fully working with percentages on
what not to use that percent money and
actually to get used to convert into
decimal here's why first let's just
write down so it's 0.06 later on you're
gonna have to work out some percentages
right like you're gonna have to use your
calculator it's gonna have to touch the
buttons you get a value out that
signifies your percentage there's
nothing you can do your calculator to
make it automatically hand you something
which says blah blah blah percent it's
always every time I'm gonna hand you a
decimal okay so you might as well get in
the pattern now of really a decimal and
interpreting the percentage over okay
it's better to get in to have it now so
you don't get confused later once you
put in twenty four hundred times 0.06
it's going to give you back looking for
fun okay great so come back now that's
the first year
okay so where do you mean the 2400 or
the 144 ah you know what it it's how
much there's import in the beginning
right and then we're going to include
the interests on top of that all right
okay so start the second year we're
going to combine these two together
alright so I'm going to get we're just
actually just going to write the sum
here and then I'm gonna work out the
bass now this is easy enough we can do
this in our heads we don't need a
calculator for this right tell me we
don't need a calculator
2544 very good still got it okay
excellent now here's the thing right
simple interest it's often also called
flat rate interest account now they're
still gonna pay me the same 144 dots
every single year like we said right at
the top right simple interest pays money
based on the initial amount they don't
care how much it's grown they're just
going back to that 2,400 okay so for
these next two cells here this is still
gonna be a hundred and forty-four and
you know what for however many years I
stay in there it's still gonna be 144
okay does that make sense every year
flat rate that's the way simple interest
works so now I can fill the rest of this
year
right at the start of the third year huh
I've had this amount of interest added
in then I've had a second amount of
interest added in so it's going to be
this is my new starting point two
thousand five and forty four and I'm
gonna get the same amount of interests
included right the wind room 44 that I
just calculated
we can still do this in our heads right
that's two thousand six hundred and
eighty-eight good oh this will be tricky
okay so now third and final year they
are on the same flat rate simple
interest two six eight eight adding on
144
2832 thank you very much Akhil
okay so correct so simple interest is
giving you the same amount wife in 44
every year every year in year out it's
all based on the initial vote that's the
lease if we just work now just to close
this off a concluding question often is
remain you gods with all of this what's
the total amount of interest in now
there are actually two ways we can work
this out have a look
look at the way the table is configured
if you wanted to work out the total
interest how would you arm what's the
first thing that jumps to mind for how
you would calculate the term is
interested so it takes the bullet eight
different ways that I'm going to you
smoke them Gary you said to take these
three minutes and to no way to say the
other one no and why is it you said
because take this three months let's
just write that down so it's 144 and it
happens three times right so I'm going
to multiply by three which is four
hundred and thirty-two of course there
is another way of doing that just by
looking at where you end and compare
that with where you started and just
take the difference right so I could
instead if I wanted to I could have done
two eight three two and subtract your
initial amount your principle yeah which
of course reassuringly gives you the
same typing thank you that we calculated
just now